foreign
Silicon Valley Nema momenti pleaded not
guilty to murder in the April 4th
stabbing of cash app founder Bob Lee
the reason the story is really
interesting is because it shows this
whole other side of San Francisco that a
lot of people are not paying attention
to initially thought by many to be a
random attack on the tech executive
here's a look at how Bob Lee knew his
alleged attacker Nima momeni and what
prosecutors say happened the night Bob
was killed
Bob Lee was a brilliant computer
programmer he is not a name that a lot
of people would recognize but he was
really influential in a lot of tech
companies out here in San Francisco
there's a lot less known about Nema
momenti and his family he immigrated
along with his sister Kazar momenti and
ended up in the Bay Area Kazar was in
the same circles as Bob Lee in this kind
of Lifestyle Circle where there's a
quite a lot of partying recreational
drug use
um different sexual partners things like
that Bob's wife Krista Lee whom he was
close with even though they were
separated disputed that he was a party
boy and said Bob was more mature than
that
Nema and Kazar were very close and Nema
was kind of over protective of his
sister a lot of the friends have told us
he was often out with her when she was
at the party scene on April 13th
authorities arrested Nema I am here
today to formally announce the charges
against Mr Nema momenti for the murder
of Bob Lee in court documents
prosecutors paint a detailed picture of
what they allege happened in the hours
leading up to Bob's death prosecutors
say that Bob and Kazar met up at a house
party on April 3rd Nema was also there
what happens next is kind of a confusing
timeline of events the important thing
to note is that at some point
Nima momenti kazar's brother confronts
Bob Lee and says did anything
inappropriate happen at that party were
there drugs did anything else happen and
Bob assures him that no nothing
inappropriate happened everything is
fine later Bob ended up at khazar's
apartment again Nemo was there
prosecutors say surveillance footage
shows Bob and Nema leaving the apartment
together in a white BMW basically
they're alleging that Nema drives the
car to a secluded spot nearby
and stabs Bob to death with a kitchen
knife
prosecutors claim Bob was left on the
street he called 9-1-1 but it was too
late and he was pronounced dead at the
hospital according to Bob's autopsy
report he was stabbed three times one
blow piercing his heart the report also
revealed that Bob had several drugs in
his system including cocaine and
ketamine
Nima momeni entered a plea of not guilty
on May 18th and is being detained ahead
of trial my defense is it's a
combination of an accident and
self-defense absolutely
it was an accident with three Stables
well you know have you ever
I'm going to say my defense is it is an
accident with
a cross between self-defense and
accident there was no premeditation
deliberation absolutely not
there's no question in our minds that we
have charged the correct person who
killed Mr Lee in a written statement
lawyers for Kazar said there are many
rumors circulating around this case many
of them untrue Ms Mo many loves and
supports her brother what happened here
is a tragedy the fact that Bob may have
been sleeping according to his friends
with Kazar the fact that Nemo was very
protective of Kazar these things
probably matter in this situation but a
lot more details about this case are
going to unfold in the coming weeks
[Music]
thank you